how are you so conservative that all of
a sudden you'll vote for anyone but
Trump 'let's let's go down the list what
happened to the pro-life principles all
of a sudden because he said something
was caught in a tape that was bad mind
you you are now going to vote for the
party who supports taxpayer-funded
abortion on demand
up until birth even for transgenders
period question of the day if you didn't
vote for people out there who didn't
vote for Trump in 2016 who identifies
sort of as Republicans conservatives are
you more or less likely to vote for him
in 2020 it's not a question for
Democrats because I know you're not
going to vote for him anyway and if you
did vote for him how would you say Trump
has done in meeting your expectations
give me a great I'm curious because I
want to talk about this state something
that really does bother but there's been
quite a bit going into 2020 we have this
group of people that never Trump errs
who are still around I guess and they've
ratcheted things up to a level that is
mind-numbing and incredibly inconsistent
what bothers me most about this is the
virtue signaling well they completely
abandon any and all principles while
trying to stand on the soapbox of I'm
making this principled decision no
you're not professional a stir of
questions three Rick Wilson let's go to
the Taylor's and an administration
defined by ignorance of the world and so
that's partly him playing to their base
also playing their audiences credulous
boomer Rosie you know that backs Donald
Trump the the Screamers and the crazy
people on the on the alt-right as they
call it you know who love Donald Trump
who who have plenty of Hitler
iconography in their Twitter icons and
they sure do is the greatest thing oh
it's it's something but the fact of the
matter is most of them are childless
single men who masturbate to anime that
last guy looked like a robot at Chuck E
Cheese nothing but a screen it Chuck
terrifying so all these people including
love to work and modern family they
claim to be Republicans of some time we
also have another tweet I just had to
include it from a Billy Crystal still
with a K not presumably forever not
perhaps for a day after November 3rd
2020 not on every issue and every way
until they but for the time being one
has to say we're all Democrats now if
one's a
[Laughter]
say okay you can be the one alright I
don't understand this we all have to say
why I don't understand this at all and
the reason they want to they claim they
won't vote for Trump is because of these
presumed consistent conservative
principles and they're so principled as
conservatives that never Trump errs that
they will abandon all of said
conservative principles he's the mean
thing so I'm going to go for open
borders and abortion yeah I don't know
what that was I knew it was close enough
cuz people will point this out yep
I was not a Trump fan in the primaries
okay no I know that a lot of people out
there were and I think there was an
appropriate time for people to be
reasonable reasonably skeptical yeah
because during the primaries especially
before 20 or even before the general
election with him and Hillary Clinton he
was an unknown entity at that point he
had been a Democrat for a very long time
as well he'd given to both parties but
we really didn't know and that was part
of his appeal was the unknown that he
was an outsider I understand it okay and
I was wrong in the sense that well I
wasn't wrong I was right to be skeptical
then but I was proven wrong in the sense
that my skepticism skeptism was
unwarranted then it was sort of
optimistic hopefully optimistic and I
will say this pleasantly surprised at
this point in 2020
is he still an unknown this is the thing
that doesn't make any sense right now I
can understand never Trump errs before
2016 right but now as we go into 2020
anyone out there who feels this way
please send me your justification how
are you so conservative that all of a
sudden you'll vote for anyone but Trump
let's let's go down the list all right
of your your principles ah the right to
life you're pro-life that's a big what
happened the pro-life principles the
doze get completely thrown out the
window the second that Donald Trump
mentioned grabbing people by the
undercarriage is that what happened so
all of a sudden because he said
something was caught in a tape that was
bad mind you you are now going to vote
for the party who supports
taxpayer-funded abortion abortion on
demand up until birth even for
transgenders period no exception tale of
a date
New York Democratic Governor Andrew
Cuomo for passing a historic bill
legalizing abortion until birth this
infanticide that we're talking about
Republican Ben Sasse blasts governor
Ralph Northam of Virginia for supporting
a bill in his state that would have
allowed abortion up until and during
birth the infant would be delivered the
infant would be resuscitated if the more
times you had the worst fashion would
ensue between the physicians and the
mothers just because a woman or let's
also not forget someone in the trans
community this poor doesn't mean they
shouldn't have the right to exercise
that right to choose Americans are poor
it's mainly the [ __ ] and balls that is
the res have an abortion
behind the important the lesser of two
evils I hear Bill Kristol and Rick
Wilson all these never trumpet by the
way you're more than welcome to come on
this show I don't hate you guys I just
think you are so woeful II wrong the
lesser of two evils would be that party
find me a single person safer Tulsi
Gabbard who has put any restrictions on
abortion whatsoever let's compare that
as a lesser of two evils to Donald Trump
who is governed is arguably the most
pro-life president ever yeah immediately
when he became president he reversed
course on the Mexico City policy was a
reverse reverse reverse that basically
mean that we're not providing abortions
are sending funding to abortions
overseas then he enabled states to cut
off federal funding to Planned
Parenthood and other abortion groups
while allowing him to provide some of
these funds to other groups that help
with crisis pregnancy that don't provide
abortion he also cut funding for the UN
Population Fund which supports abortion
forced sterilization in China and then
of course he also rolled back the
Obamacare Obamacare birth control
mandate that would force employers to
have to pay for what they believe to be
abort if against is it a part of the
concern board officiants like militia
gets the point is he couldn't be more
pro-life as far as how he has governed
not to mention the Supreme Court and you
talk about lesser of two evils president
Trump's Department of Health Health and
Human Services define life is beginning
at conception which really isn't all
that radical considering that's every
science textbook ever
yeah it's radical then and he was a
first-timer to go to march for life and
some people which was huge well some
people say that was a political move
here's the thing I understand let's say
that all of this and all of these steps
were just political moves they were
calculated who cares if your reason for
not supporting Donald Trump in 2020 is
your principles you should still be
happy with the outcome at this point
let's go to the second amendment
equipment this matters the lesser of two
evils Oh what happened here Pro Second
Amendment principles won't even get into
the First Amendment today because we
know that's a lost cause for democratic
party the Second Amendment let's just go
down the list to number two did those
get thrown out of the window because now
you can vote for a party who they want
to ban all semi automatic semi-automatic
would include nearly all handguns and
firearms do you want to create a
national registry and the Justice
justices by the way the left's justices
have actually argued that private
citizens have no right to owning
firearms whatsoever this is the lesser
of two evils
yes we're gonna take your ar-15 your
ak-47 amen
I think there would be a visit by law
enforcement to recover that firearm and
I'm sure that it is purchased bought
back so that it cannot be potentially
used against somebody else the only way
better work is wielding an ak-47 is if
an ACME white flag going powerfully
nevertrump errs it's the lesser of two
evils on the second I'm an under
President Trump we've seen rollback of
Obama air regulations right they took up
fighter low nose took gun rights away
from seniors merely because they needed
help managing money Wow and so they were
deems to be mentally defensive basically
and also of course President Trump he
hasn't done a lot for the second diamond
but here's the thing Republicans don't
need to do that much they just need to
not budge as it relates to us
maintaining our second is maintaining so
no change after of course the assault
weapons ban was basically rolled back
that doesn't exist anymore is good
that's a good thing we don't want change
all the time so President Trump not
changing a whole lot and having
simultaneously promised to veto any
Democrats ridiculous attempts at gun
legislation I think it's a pretty good
thing and again if you are saying I will
vote for anyone not named Donald Trump
what are the Democrats offering never
Trump errs what are they offering
what's that sensible middle ground is it
domestic abusers can't get no we already
have that is it having to pass a
background check no we already have it
it's banning all semi-automatic weapons
and Firearms and have magazine
capacities or at least banning the
magazines that are over ten rounds like
we have in California then forcing
people F to register for ammo is that we
were talking that's the middle ground
from the left so we'd love to know Anna
Navarro and Rick Wilson and Billy
Crystal what do the Democrats offer you
that you see is the lesser of evil in
comparison to Trump's evil let's go to
the economy right because I wanted to
start off with pro-life let's start
second Ahmet kind of moral issues let's
go - lets go - something
results-oriented
what but on the principle what about
supporting a free market economy free
enterprise that's one of the most hey
that's the basic tenets of conservatism
toss it you people vote for the Democrat
because they're not Trump okay
so I understand this so the only the
only logical alternative to President
Donald Trump in the case of the economy
is self without socialists your
alternative never jumpers is someone
like Bernie right now who thinks that a
90% top tax rate isn't too high lest you
think
make this up radical-socialist like the
Eisenhower was president I think the
highest marginal tax rate for something
like thank you
it was ninety when you think about
ninety percent you don't think that's
obviously too high placing the ball on
the flip side if we're talking about the
lesser of two evils you have president
Donald Trump whose tax cuts have reduced
sit tax bill for those earning a median
income here now it's right around the
averaged about sixty percent
mm-hmm that sounds substantive and well
we're talking about not to sound like a
broken record we have record low
unemployment we have record low layoffs
we have more job participation than
we've ever had of course we see huge
increases and household income wage
growth that's an argument that's gone
away record-breaking stock market and I
do what I would love to be a Democrat in
2020 I want to see their sell when they
try to tell the American public that
they've been screwed by a president who
has created record low unemployment
record high wage growth stock market
values and as they pick as they stop to
fill their tank with top it off with
some gas on the way to the polls that
evening it's a buck forty five it's hard
to sell that message that you need
change when that's going that's why the
Democrats have to now they're not LBJ
they're not JFK they're not the party of
the working class families they have to
go to identity politics and that's why
it's now the party of social justice
warriors because they can't argue on the
economy average Americans including
average black Americans minorities
period across the board all of them are
doing better now anyone want to argue
that people are doing they're worse off
than seven years ago under President
Obama leave your comments I'd love to
see you heckled out of the Congress
let's go to immigration never Trump furs
your principles immigration so let's be
really clear Democrats not only want a
socialist health care system and I mean
that a socialized health care system I
come from what I'm not using as a racist
dog whistle I come from a place where
I've very relatives who could not get
the kind of care that they would get
here in the United States it's a place
called Canada kind of little country to
the north of us look it up America's
have they not they not only want to have
a socialized health care system which
would put people in shallow graves
they want to extend that socialized
healthcare to all citizens or
non-citizens raise your hand if covered
if your government plan would provide
coverage for undocumented immigrants one
or two they were like all right I hope
someone's watching this is changing my
website start a petition oh yeah senator
Sanders even advocates completely
pausing all deportations even for and
this is important
wait for it convicted violent criminals
so we're gonna end the ice raids which
are terrorizing communities all across
this country enforcing the law are gonna
impose a moratorium on deportations
okay so we're all Democrats really one
must say that Bill Kristol
we're all Democrats let's pause violent
criminals being deported let's give them
all free health care because that's a
that's a less radical idea than building
a wall on the border right I mean this
is something - this is the bait and
switch that you see from Democrats right
you see this a lot we've had this was
changed my mind when people talk about
immigration they go what about what
about dreamers you know is weak some
people use a term Anchorage but what
about the babies who through no fault of
their own their parents migrated here
illegally should they no you know what
you don't care about that that's not
where RI penny opinions diverge and
that's why I don't believe in trying to
find a middle ground because if we were
to say okay how about this dreamers all
the children of illegal immigrants they
can stay everyone else gets the boot no
no for a second where do you believe we
should draw the line do you believe in
deporting violent felons who are here
illegally and overcrowding our prison
systems health care yeah just like with
abortion right they say what about cases
of rape and incest you don't care about
that
why okay if I were to say all right all
rape and incest cases abortion no
questions asked can we no no no well
hold a second where do you draw the line
no Democrat not one outside of Tulsi
Gabbard could give an answer outside
woman's right to choose and that's why
we see policies as you see in Virginia
that that basically occurs up until
crowning so let's not act as though we
divert that our opinions start all of a
sudden there's a gap right once we
arrive at rape and incest or once we
arrive at the idea of anchor babies if
you don't believe in deporting violent
felons period and you don't believe that
there should be any limitations on
abortion period as a party Democrat so
never jumpers ask you again how do you
lock arms with these people go to a
deficit here's where you might have a
point right that Donald Trump hasn't
balanced the budget and I you know yes I
agree I have a problem with that I have
a problem the deficit I think it's
inconsistent for people who are so upset
with Barack Obama to give Donald Trump a
free pass
got it that's a valid point but neither
did george w bush hmm yeah what about
George Bush Senior what about Ronald
Reagan and and again what's most
important is you need to compare Donald
Trump's transgressions with what you
know would be policy coming from the
left do we think that any of the current
Democratic nominees would balance a
budget more conservatively than Donald
Trump
take your pick Bernie Warren but it
anyone but gig but gig but gig anyone
and this is the point it would make
President Trump for all of us folks he's
governed more conservatively than
arguably any president in modern history
despite the fact that he probably isn't
as conservative personally as maybe some
some of the previous Republican
presidents I don't know I don't have any
reason to believe that he's super
liberal have any reason to believe that
he's super conservative personally but
as far as the record here yeah it speaks
for itself and my point is yes again
2016 conservatives were right to be a
little bit suspicious of Donald Trump
and that was again part of his appeal
but that's not the case any more he's
not an unknown entity he's done more for
a conservative Christian Americans and
the American economy arguably than any
president in modern history in 2020 I
want to be really clear never Trump errs
it's not a vote between the lesser of
two evils not even close this is a
choice between an imperfect president as
all presidents before him
who's governed at least as
conservatively as any Republican in
recent memory at least comparably
conservatively okay your choices between
that
and a party of evil it couldn't be more
clear it's not Oh you we're all
Democrats now you're all Democrats
because you're principled you are all
Democrats now precisely because you are
unprincipled precisely because you're
blind disdain for president Trump
overruled all of the conservative
principles that you claim to hold so
dear so Donald Trump said grab them by
the puppy so I support Ralph Northam and
his platform you know the drill just
click one of these other videos in a box
playing up here and I mean by there's an
actual box I don't of course mean that
in the feminine it's a slur but that of
course I don't mean box because men can
have boxes too and I don't mean to say
box I just that men can there's like a
DC outlet an AC outlet and they can be
either one that they choose depending on
the electrical current or tha'ts charge
of ions I think